I'm often heard to say there should be
no rule in the kitchen or the bedroom
my name is meathead and I run the
world's most popular barbecue and
grilling websites
it's called amazing ribs dot-com
anything you cook indoors you can cook
outdoors only better we're standing on
my deck and this is my lap at this point
in time I probably have eighteen to
twenty grills on hand this is where we
do experiment we're constantly trying to
cook outside the box well today I
thought I would show you something
unusual so I'm gonna take a bushel
basket full of grape vines and stuff it
into a weber kettle to the top I'm gonna
torch them from below and it's gonna
make a massive flame but when the flames
die down we get this bed of really hot
coals I'm gonna put this flank steak
directly over the coals and I'm gonna
sear it and turn it and sear it and turn
it I'm gonna keep turning it so that it
gets a good dark surface but it doesn't
get too much heat down into the center
what a lot of people don't understand is
they think the hot air is what cooks the
meat all the way through but in fact hot
air inside your grill cooks only the
outside of the meat it's the outside of
the meat that cooks the inside of the
meat 1:06 I need a little more time
another important technique that we
preach is thermometers meat is done when
the thermometer says is not the clock
132 medium-rare steak is 130 degrees
approximately an end is done we should
get really good juicy medium-rare flank
steaks with a great crust on them and
then we're gonna cut those flank steaks
on a bias across the grain and we're
gonna have hopefully very juicy very
tender meat I just love what I do and I
hope it shows in the food
you